in order to show up as a husband and as
a father I have to take care of myself
physically and mentally and that is love
for those other people around me just as
much as it is love for myself because if
I'm not doing those things I'm not the
type of person that I want to be I'm not
taking care of myself in the way that I
should and I can't show up for them and
for me that means I need to do 60
Minutes of physical activity a day I
need to get in the cold plunge every
single morning and I need to be outside
and going for a couple of walks every
single day if I do those three things I
know no matter what everything else can
go to and my day is great in that
regard and I'm able to show up in the
way that I want to